it's not like uh the New York Times has
not covered the idea of a lab leak at
all or other uh large prestigious
organizations it's just that there's a
sort of a symmetry because I think it
goes back to these this network that
you're talking about it's it's it's kind
of understandable you have of
respectable scientists saying one thing
they might have motives for saying that
thing but then that is what gets treated
as more cred right out of the gate and
like one striking example to me was the
way that this this is a New York Times
article on the pre-print uh on the kind
of definitive paper that's making the
argument that this uh spillover from
animals to humans happened at the Hunan
Market New research points to Wuhan
Market as pandemic origin and kind of
the the way this was reported you see a
quote from Michael Warby one of the lead
authors on it when you look at the
evidence all together it's an
extraordinarily clear picture that the
pandemic started in the Hunan Market
some of those conclusions were softened
a little bit once this went through peer
review uh notes there that it at the
time of publication in the New York
Times it had not yet been published in a
scientific journal um I I I do want to
like you know talk a little bit about
like the the way that was covered but
also about the study itself um maybe
Alex could weigh in in on this um
they're arguing that the the the the
argument of the paper is they did
samples uh in the market and you can see
in this diagram there's a little red hot
spot where they're saying most of the
virus was uh
transmitted uh or or you know the hot
spot of viral samples was in this little
corner like like one or two stalls and
then if you zoom in on that you'll see
they've got you know these two stalls
kind of highlighted in red and they've
got pictures of raccoon dogs and uh
unknown Birds these uh ma basically
mammals that plausibly could have
transmitted the virus from um uh two
human beings in the market and and
kicked this pandemic off what uh this is
the this and one other paper who was was
by many of the same authors are kind of
like the touchstones for like th this is
the definitive argument for zoonotics
spillover of the virus which which is
which is a very common way for pandemics
to start what is your analysis uh in
short of of this paper
Alex I if you could keep up that figure
that's actually a great great touch
Point um so this analysis made a
statistical error and the error fails to
account for sampling bias
um if you look at that little gradiation
of number of environmental positives at
the middle kind of near the bottom there
that's the statistic that they were
analyzing and so yeah it looks like
there's a high number of environmental
positives in this lower left quadrant
however we we pointed out that the
Chinese researchers who conducted this
work said in their methods they are
prioritizing samples near animal stalls
so they took more samples that's why
there's a higher number of samples if
you look at the percent of samples that
test positive they were actually highest
near vegetable Traders and in the toilet
in the sewage so which tells a very
different epidemiological story of human
to human transmission and another point
to you know on the broader um topic of
War be it out they looked at where are
cases found within the city of Wuhan and
they said ah well these cases found
within the city of Wuhan with Asis cases
provided by the Chinese government were
centralized localized around the Wuhan
the huan seafood market however when you
do a statistical analysis of those data
you find that the unlined cases um are
actually closer to the seafood market
which suggests that these cases did have
this bias and case ascertainment
furthermore there were Cases left out of
this analysis cases that preceded the
wet Market outbreak for instance a
December 4th report of a SARS
coronavirus case in Wuhan that coincided
with an uptic of the use of the word
SARS in the Chinese social media app
weebo so that those two data points
corroborate this case preceding the wet
Market outbreak and furthermore there
was another analysis of these care
seeking terms that are less likely to
have been filtered which showed that the
earlier hotspot of care seeking term
usage in Wuhan was on the other side of
the river near a hospital that's one of
the closest hospitals to the Wuhan
Institute of biology so when we try to
look at these independent lines to
corroborate this and when we account for
the statistical biases their findings
don't hold their claim of dispositive
evidence hasn't lasted the test of time
so that's the warbow paper and most of
us who were in the field knew that right
away David rman called this hopelessly
impoverished early case data um and it
was quite evident that that was the case
so for us scientists in the field it's
unusual that these two papers the other
one had similar statistical flaws and a
bug in its code that completely
undermined it these two papers were both
published side by side in science and
then both presented in the New York
Times and the Atlantic and the guardian
as you know dis positive evidence it's
been Sol
and for many of us scientists especially
me familiar with the standards of
evidence in the field before Co for
instance looking at the percent of PCR
tests that are positive which we all
know was a big debate during covid in
terms of how to measure prevalence in
the population um to control for
increasing rates of testing you know for
us who are familiar with the standards
of evidence and the common modes of
analysis in the field these papers were
highly unusual so was the proximal
origin paper by these same authors and
then you trace it back to the wall and
you find that Anthony F
who funded the diffused pis in
2019 he prompted this call he put the
people in the room and who did he put in
the room with Christian Anderson and Edy
Holmes he put in the leading proponents
of gain of function research including
the OG Ron fusier who passaged that Aven
influenza through ferret so this was you
know it's like the EPA calling in all
the oil and gas companies when they're
presented with a study finding evidence
of climate change you know when us
scientists who are familiar with the
other scientists and the debates in the
field and the methods and modes of
analysis when we see this it's just a it
that to me is Raising alarm bells in
addition to the genomic evidence of the
fear and cleavage site not just any fear
and cleavage site you know but a fear
and cleavage site in the exact position
where Emily's recently foiled documents
proposed to insert it um in Wuhan where
this was proposed to be conducted and
far from the Hotpot of bat SARS Corona
viruses and a Litany of other evidence
that all combined and I think for me
that's how I think of the evidence is we
have to treat these zootic origin papers
methodically and look at them carefully
and see how much evidence they do
provide once we throw those off the
table based on their statistical flaws
and other other problems with them all
that's left is this mountain of evidence
you know it's like the straw that broke
the camel's back we're looking for that
straw but we're forgetting about the
many bales of hay that are already there
and that's you know our paper was yet
another straw but Emily is right to
point out and think about this evidence
you have to look at everything you have
to look at the Wuhan origin the fur and
cleavage site at the S1 S2 Junction with
these weird codons bio Engineers use
with all this weird Behavior both of the
Chinese government and the researchers
connected with the Wuhan labs and
coincidentally we found evidence
consistent with the exact method for
assembly that they proposed and that
every time we foil new documents we only
get closer to the truth that
corroborates this Theory we've had all
along so what does this all say about
the state of science journalism
Emily Emily do you want to take that
I've got opinions but I feel like you
have some good ones too yeah um I feel
like I could rant about this all day but
I think just taking the warb paper as an
example um I mean some of the stuff
we're discussing is very high level and
maybe the journalists just didn't
understand you might say but remember
that at the point that that preprint
came out and the New York Times push
alerted it the senior authors of that
paper had been caught lying already we
already had the Foyd emails showing that
Anderson said that the SARS K2 genome
had features consistent with engineering
and then four days later told the
nationaly that um that that was a crank
Theory um and we already knew that
Robert Gary another author on that paper
um had said I can't figure out how this
Spike protein gets accomplished in
nature but it would be easy to do in a
lab and then you know a few days later
started drafting a paper that would
dismiss the idea of engineering as a
conspiracy theory so these people were
already not credible you know and Zack
you were talking about how you know
people's default is often well this
person has a lot of expertise they're
affiliated with this prestigious
institution they seem the the most
credible and um in 99% of cases I would
agree but I think we're in this unique
situation where we're trusting
virologists to give us straight answer
straight answers about whether a
pandemic that killed millions of people
stemmed from controversial virology
research um and you know these
virologists in particular already at
this point had a track record of
dishonesty um and I think when you're a
reporter I think you have to have some
healthy
skepticism
and you know Prestige is important
expertise is important but so is
integrity and I remember when this you
know paper got a lot of attention in the
Press I mean the New York Times alerted
it CNN alerted it a bunch of other news
organizations I remember thinking you
know does honesty not matter does
integrity not matter um I think it
clearly matters and um you
know another aspect here um that should
have alerted journalists to
something strange going on was the fact
that I mean literally hours before the
war be preprint published the China CDC
had come out with its own analysis um in
a preprint of this data and they had
concluded that the wet Market was a
super spreader event that it had just
Amplified an already existing epidemic
um you know that conclusion happens to
um be consistent with their Count's
propaganda around the pandemic starting
somewhere else but they did collect the
data um and they have more knowledge
about how they collected their own data
than Western scientists working on
laptops many miles away and what they
said was exactly what Alex just said
which is that you know these samples
that appear to Cluster around the animal
s we actually focused our our collection
efforts there um and Jesse Bloom has
analyzed the metagenomic data and found
that um animal DNA specifically animals
that could have served as intermediate
hosts like raccoon dogs um is uh not
correlated with SARS
K2 virus um and so those samples are not
very meaningful which China CDC knew and
said right before um The New York Times
put on its front page that it was
definitely the wet market and the labl
theory is a conspiracy theory um and I
think the more information we've gotten
um the less and less these papers have
stood up recently two experts in spatial
statistics put out a paper basically
saying that the war be paper is
extremely flawed um but there hasn't
been a lot of followup that I've seen in
the western media at least to correct
the record and to also look at some of
the evidence that's accumulated on the
lab side so um there's a lack of like
followup also I don't know that I am
hoping for any specific policy outcome
um or change in the Press I just
honestly want there to be Clarity and a
national Reckoning for everyone who lost
loved ones to the pandemic um or who
lost businesses or major milestones in
their life um I I honestly think this
will probably be my last investigation
and have kind of been approaching it
that way I don't have a lot of hope that
you know journalism will tomorrow be
like actually this is very valuable
reporting um and we should reward it I
think um I just want there to
be Clarity and some closure for people
who are grieving that's really my my one
hope so well that that's kind of
surprising and and disappointing what
why is this why are you thinking this is
your last investigation are you just
like there's you're you've hit a brick
wall I don't know that I will be
employable after
this at least in the media as it exists
now so um yeah so I I don't I guess
think a lot about like this is how I
want the press to change you know I I
just want there to be Clarity around
this kind of most um Monumental thing
that has happened um in modern times so
that's really My Hope hey thanks for
watching that clip from our new show
just asking questions you can watch
another clip here or the full episode
here new episodes drop every week so
subscribe to reent TV's YouTube channel
to get notified when that happens
or to the just asking questions podcast
on Apple Spotify or any other podcaster
see you next week